[Music]
James congratulations where are you
right now thank you I appreciate it i'm
actually on the black hand for the
parade who's on the bus with you uh my
girlfriend my cousin their blood be on
Lewis but other guys from theme and
busker families cope just a guys look
refreshed or look really tired buh-bye
pressures going to be a great time to
get out and celebrate with fans are the
best fans in there and the country so
may be a great fit oh I like that the
running back go together on the bus was
that by design that you and LeGarrette
and Dion would be on the bus yeah we all
our time together um hang out on and off
the vehicle p1 and I have fun so for a
tight-knit group and the kind of special
relationship with one another uh I think
it makes our cream better can you yell
over to Dion and just ask him how his
hamstring is because we are worried
about it when we were watching the game
is he okay all right I'd be on it want
me to do with it so how you hamstring
yeah it's great ok that's an official
diagnosis that Dion's hamstrings great
all right good all right take me into
the huddle right before the game winning
play what what is that play called and
what are you thinking when Brady calls
it I mean it's a cosplay I knew the ball
comes amigo so everything wearing
clothes it could be uh topically to get
the ball my hands no and then in the
game I saw a little cruise has run 31
guy I just did whatever just get the
ball and does make a killer but uh
that's one to wonder for my teammates
it's grateful to God like one another
and uh I mean happy for a good guy what
did you do with the football I actually
don't know what I did was it bad oh no
no yeah I left it on the ground star run
so hopeless Eva Maria
you're over dave has that for me in
equipment room James you're supposed to
save that stub I know I wasn't thinking
about that in that moment I was stupid
Britain battlefield look what did you
keep from that game I kept my first
touchdown balls but I really haven't
kept anything else of everything came
back to the equipment room and all other
side without try to keep as much as I
can blush they let me because now Tom
gave you his gym VP car yeah I haven't
actually received out how that works I
think you got to go to his house to pick
it up James I think yeah somebody drop
you off there I'll garba kind of cool ah
what did you say to Tom when he told you
that he thought you should have been MVP
and you deserved the car I mean it's
just a component words but he loved the
servant of everything he gives me one
being that positional in the game
without him I would get the ball I
wasn't a fan fortune recession I've been
working for him so he's our leader I
mean I can't take any credit Eddie's
made it pretty cool that he I mean
humbling up those good to give me the
car always tank me and in hip hop great
teammate what was half son like I oh ok
well I think we're losing you thought I
got a rello hope I'll have a lot of
energy guys want to fly around display
our best football let me lose it for
that for what was the postgame
celebration link I was a lot of fun all
our teammates re gonna be still feel
kinda surreal to come back from such a
such a big deficit but maybe as we had
painted in with guys to fight no matter
what no matter what's on the scoreboard
would be up for your down for the
contrary to fight one another Oh we'd
like a contribution to the man cave if
you'd like you know could we get maybe
one sock from the super
full performance there for our man can
Oh what's your our career all right make
sure you sign it and we'd love to
display it here in the man cave all
right I got you James congratulations
well done great game glad you got some
recognition and have fun today you
certainly deserve it I appreciate ur
night there's James White Patriots
running back another contribution to the
man cave it's always nice when you're
asking them live you know and kind of
guilting them into giving you something
but that's okay that's way to do it yeah
and it's not beneath us to beg yeah yeah
man I got two sure look at that I'm sure
or about it yeah kind of little you know
other people ask for jerseys we ask for
socks the Dan Patrick show weekday
morning on audience
[Music]